[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
avec la déclaration de guerre de la
Fédération de Russie à l'Ukraine et la
violation de son territoire par l'armée
russe
le 24 février dernier
l'impensable est revenu en Europe
par cet acte la Russie a enfin toutes
les règles du droit international et
bafouer les valeurs de paix et de
liberté sur lesquelles le continent
européen a construit son équilibre
depuis plusieurs décennies
depuis ce 24 février le peuple ukrainien
se bat sans relâche pour préserver son
indépendance et sa démocratie les forces
ukrainiennes ont ardemment résisté
privant les autorités russes d'une
victoire rapide le courage des
Ukrainiens force le respect
l'objectif de la prise de Kiev a été
abandonné et l'armée russe a été
contrainte de se regrouper vers l'Est et
le Sud du pays la récente
contre-offensive ukrainienne dans les
régions de carquif et Carson a permis la
reprise d'une part importante du
territoire
si le peuple ukrainien peut espérer et
entrevoir un avenir de paix préservant
sa démocratie et son indépendance c'est
aussi grâce à l'action résolue de la
France de son président et des Européens
oui dès le début du conflit nous avons
fait preuve de fermeté
et nous avons réaffirmé des valeurs nos
valeurs
nous avons agi avec fermeté face aux
mensonges du pouvoir russe et ses
menaces contre la sécurité
internationale nous avons montré que nos
institutions étaient fortes et pouvaient
réagir rapidement
par une résolution de la semblée
générale des Nations unies une large
majorité des pays du monde à un effet
condamné l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie dès le début du conflit l'Ukraine
a pu bénéficier d'une aide financière
militaire et humanitaire
nous avons aussi réaffirmé nos valeurs
elles ont d'ailleurs été rappelées à la
communauté internationale par le
Président de la République lui-même lors
de son allocution aux Nations Unies le
20 septembre dernier un ordre
international fondé sur la défense des
droits humains un respect de la
souveraineté de chacun et une
coopération renforcée tels sont les
principes fondateurs du système
multilatéral seul garant de la paix
le président de la République a
également réaffirmé lors de cette
intervention le choix diplomatique
partagé avec nos partenaires européens
mettre fin à la guerre sans devenir
belligérant
mettre fin à la guerre pour le peuple
crânien nous devons au peuple craignant
de mettre face à cette guerre et à cette
crise humanitaire aux conséquences
dramatiques de nombreuses
infrastructures ont été touchées et les
bombardements des zones de conflits font
constamment de nouvelles victimes déjà
plus de 5000 civils femmes hommes et
enfants ont été tués arrachés à leur
famille et à leurs proches les exactions
sont nombreuses les images du massacre
de boucha le bombardement d'une
maternité à Mario Paul la découverte de
fosses communes aux abords d'izum
ravivent les heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire toute la lumière devra
être faite sur ses crimes en particulier
dans le cadre de l'enquête ouverte par
la Cour pénale internationale
mettre fin à la guerre c'est aussi un
gage de stabilité pour notre continent à
cet égard le discours du président russe
vendredi au ton messianique et
violemment antioxydantal nous démontre
qui ne reculera malheureusement devant
rien pour autant nous devons pas être
des belligérants le peuple russe ne nous
le pardonnerait pas nous ne pouvons
entrer en guerre contre un peuple
victime d'un régime autoritaire qui
l'isole du reste du monde et le mobilise
de force dans un conflit d'un autre
temps il est primordial comme tente de
le faire la France de poursuivre le
dialogue avec la Russie il s'agit là
d'une condition essentielle pour établir
durablement la paix sur le continent
européen
ma conviction est la suivante refuser la
belligérance ne nous condamne nullement
à l'impuissance avec ses partenaires
européens la France a imposé à la Russie
de multiples sanctions et ses sanctions
sont efficaces elles ont en effet privé
le régime de ressources majeures pour
financer et approvisionner ses efforts
de guerre les importations de la Russie
ont chuté des composants essentiels de
son industrie d'armement sont manquantes
son matériel militaire est devenu
défectueux souvent à l'abandon au bord
des routes sur le front
j'entends dire ici ou là que ces
sanctions seraient plus dur à porter
pour nous que pour les Russes
s'agit là d'un mensonge malheureusement
répandu au moyen de campagne de
désinformation successives non seulement
ces sanctions fonctionnent à l'endroit
du régime russe mais en plus leur effet
sur l'économie française reste marginale
d'une part parce que la crise
alimentaire est économique que nous
subissons n'est pas due au seul fait de
la guerre en Ukraine et de ses
conséquences d'autre part parce que les
promesses du Président de la République
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français ont été tenus
outre leurs mensonges les autorités
russes et leur relais médiatique
entretiennent un climat de terreur par
des chantages abjects sur notre
souveraineté et notre sécurité
collective chantage énergétique d'abord
jouant avec la dépendance des pays
européens au gaz russe chantage
alimentaire ensuite les blocus en mer
noirs ont durablement impacté les
marchés céréaliers mondiaux aggravant la
crise alimentaire en Afrique où la
France est directement engagée dans des
opérations de stabilisation et de
développement
chantage nucléaire enfin alors qu'un
régime acculée n'a d'autres solutions
que de rappeler au monde sa capacité
destructrice
ultime
nous aurons toujours à cœur d’écouter de
comprendre et de répondre aux
préoccupations des Français mais face au
chantage des autorités russes il ne faut
pas céder et nous ne céderons pas ni au
chantage énergétique ni au chantage
alimentaire encore moins au chantage
nucléaire
pour autant et je le répète notre combat
né et ne doit jamais être dirigé contre
le peuple russe c'est avant tout un
combat pour pour protéger des valeurs
démocratiques jusqu'au bord de l'Europe
pour garantir notre indépendance
énergétique et alimentaire pour défendre
notre sécurité et construire notre
autonomie stratégique trop souvent nos
valeurs démocratiques notre attachement
aux libertés publiques au droit de
l'homme sont mises en danger par ceux
qui veulent les faire passer pour des
marques de faiblesse à cela nous disons
que les démocraties sont fortes et
qu'elles sont capables de surmonter les
crises mes chers collègues il nous faut
donc encore faire preuve de fermeté
restez ferme sur nos valeurs c'est
savoir dire non aux alliances de
circonstances avec les démagogues de
tout bord au sein de l'Union européenne
où le populisme gagne chaque jour un peu
plus de terrain restons aussi
inflexibles que déterminés alors que
beaucoup pensent trouver leur salut dans
les extrêmes rappelons-nous de la place
que l'histoire accordent aux dirigeants
qui oppriment leur peuple
cette fermeté doit s'accompagner de
lucidité sans arrogance la démocratie ne
se décrète pas il ne s'impose elle reste
hélas parfois un régime d'exception en
témoigne le refus de certains pays qui
comptabilisent la majorité de la
population mondiale de condamner
clairement l'agression de l'Ukraine
l'engagement sans fin des ukrainien pour
leur démocratie doit être un espoir et
une source d'inspiration pour tous les
peuples mais c'est aussi la preuve que
ce monde plus ouvert et plus libre
auquel nous croyons n'a rien d'évident
madame la Première ministre nous vivons
des situations de vertige face à eux la
voie tracée par la France et la bonne et
la seule voie possible vous pouvez
compter sur le groupe que j'ai l'honneur
de présider comme vous pouvez compter
sur l'ensemble des députés élus attaché
à la démocratie à la liberté à celle de
nos enfants car nous savons désormais
que la liberté n'est plus anakie elle
est plus que jamais un combat
un combat de chaque instant ce qui se
joue donc en Ukraine est essentiel nous
ne voulons pas la guerre avec la Russie
mais ne nous pouvons pas la laisser
gagner cette guerre l'Ukraine c'est la
France c'est la démocratie c'est la
liberté je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]